the first kind sighting the second kind
evidence the third kind contact the
fourth kind disappointing movie so I was
pumped for this movie is it too good to
be true that a ghost and an alien movie
can both be released about the same time
of year and give me that same feeling of
dread as I lay in bed waiting for the
inevitable well you know how the phrase
goes if it's too good to be true yeah
this movie blows the Fourth Kind tries
to jump on the whole mockumentary
bandwagon by claiming to mix in real
audio and video of real hypnotherapy
sessions to bring some sort of validity
to this movie I mean when most people
see video in a scary movie they just
assume that it's real but it's just some
false assumption on their part but the
marketing department for this movie
straight up claim that this is real
footage and evidence but it's not it's
[ __ ] look we all gobbled up that
marketing ploy with Blair which in 2000
we're not falling forward again
now the reason Paranormal Activity
didn't piss me off is because it was
never boasted to be real footage yeah it
was shot to look like it but they said
from the beginning that it was fictional
from the start paranormal activity was
said to be a David in a world of Goliath
it was a fictional movie that just cost
11 grand to make but the Fourth Kind
goes so bold as to say it has real
footage the stuff that proof is made of
the most compelling evidence of alien
abduction ever caught on camera it
claims to be Goliath the Father the Son
and the Holy Ghost of documented
evidence but to name a couple of
loopholes in that [ __ ]
one the real names of the people
involved have supposedly been changed to
protect their identities but during this
real archive footage they never blur
their faces out what is that you change
their names but you don't blur their
faces out that is key we can see who
they are I mean change their names all
you want but if you don't blur their
faces out it's all useless we can see
who they are anyone who's anyone knows
that when you're protecting someone's
identity on camera you make them sound
like Bea Arthur and RuPaul's love child
and you film it like this so you'll
steal they came out of the sky
they made me watch transformers 202
there is this scene where this guy flips
out and kills people and it's supposedly
one of these moments with real video I'm
not talking some world's scariest police
videos [ __ ] where some car wrecks and
people die no I'm talking people get
shot in the face they die you see it and
supposedly it's real yeah at that point
that is called a snuff film not a rated
pg-13 movie at the very least the movie
would have been rated R if it were real
and if you want to go even simpler this
is supposedly the most compelling real
evidence of alien abduction ever and
we've never seen it it supposedly has
existed for nine years and we've never
seen it anywhere anything ever filmed in
the history of ever is on the Internet
we've never seen this if this footage
had existed it would have been on the
internet and it would have gone more
viral than a crossbreed between the
swine flu and Paris Hilton's pap smear
so now that we know it's [ __ ] the
only gimmick that made this movie
remotely interesting-looking is gone
eradicated it is done so how do we live
in a world where paranormal activity
entertained me infinitely more than the
Fourth Kind when the Fourth Kind
actually had more going on in it tell
you the truth I don't know it's kind of
like trying to explain why I prefer
redheads to blonds I just do well what
can I say paranormal activity kept me on
edge I wanted to see what would happen
next and when something did happen
sometimes it genuinely chilled me then
when I went home I couldn't stop
thinking about it saw the Fourth Kind
went home slept like a baby haven't
thought about her since until right now
here I'll describe the Fourth Kind
imagined paranormal activity where when
anything would happen on camera which is
what you're waiting for the camera would
freak out and scramble up like the spice
Channel in the 90s when you didn't
subscribe to it distort scramble and go
blank I mean come on guys we know that
gimmick is [ __ ] so just show us
something don't scramble the videos
don't give us broken audio give us
something to talk about at least we'll
have something to talk about rest
assured after this video I will never
talk about the Fourth Kind ever again
there will be no need to there's nothing
I'm pissed about it all just nothing the
movie forever yeah there's an
interesting subject or so in the movie
talking about aliens depicted on ancient
tablets and whatnot but it's in like one
scene in the movie so what I can go rent
stargate have a movie deal with that
topic for two solid hours or watch the
TV show that dealt with it for ten
seasons so skip this [ __ ] and rent an
alien movie with better content like
yeah hayley shall have some payoff and
at least one scene
you